I'm gonna be honest with you I have
envisioned killing bosses before I've
had some bad ones Horrible Bosses is
directed by Seth Gordon who directed
king of Kong A Fistful of quarters and
Four Christmases weird combination and
now he's directing this movie which
stars Jason Bateman Jason Sudeikis
Charlie Day Jennifer Aniston Jamie Foxx
Colin Farrell Kevin Spacey and Donald
Sutherland in a very brief role I'll sum
of the pup pretty quickly this is a
comedy about three guys who have three
bosses that they cannot stand seeing
these bosses made me feel like wow I
really didn't have too much to deal with
because these people are just horrific
ly horrible people I mean they're there
is there a bad boss they're bad people
they're just terrible people so they
started to come up with a way to get rid
of their bosses they literally start to
plan some elaborate scheme so their
bosses will die in some way it is
hilarious cuz we reminded me of like
older comedies from the 70s and 80s
worth it'd be just one giant scheme that
just fell flat in every way and just
problems arose and you know constant
running and trying to fix everything and
everything just falling apart and it's
hilarious every other scene it's like oh
my gosh what are they doing how are they
getting into these situations it's one
of those kind of comedies and I love
comedies like that they're just like
scene after scene after scene of the
home my word and the hope to Jason
Bateman is very funny this movie and as
usual he's playing more of a straight
man Jason Sudeikis is also he is really
funny in this movie he might he may have
even been the funniest person Charlie
Day had definitely definitely funny at
parts but I think he just got a little
bit too crazy at times and went a little
overboard that was just me some people
might really find it hilarious he did
get on my nerves a little bit towards
the latter half of the film but I still
enjoy him in the movie
just got on my nerves a little bit as
for the bosses Kevin Spacey is just
relishing this role of this just
horrifically terrible person who he
pretends he's going to promote people
that just doesn't and Colin Farrell he
just tells Jason today gets to fire all
the fat people can fire all the people
who have any type of disability he's
just a terrible person he is also very
funny which Jennifer Aniston usually
with her she always kind of plays a very
similar character in all her films that
seems kind of like how she is in real
life because of that I've always like
yeah you know whenever done Cranston
however in this movie her role is
basically to be incredibly hot and let
me tell you she did some oscar-worthy
work I also really like Jamie Foxx this
movie he was relishing it as this guy
they go to it he called himself the
murder consultant he doesn't want to get
his hands dirty though but he just kind
of sits back nice IKEA this is what you
do I'll tell you what to do and he just
he relished it he that was good I didn't
really have any big issues with the film
at all it was a very funny film from
start to finish I can't really bring out
in the glaring flaws some person might
be like the premise of this movies is
evil they're trying to kill someone you
gotta realize the tone of this film is
not serious the only issue I had at the
film's is that Charlie Day got on my
nerves a little bit other than that I
had a lot of fun with the movie it's a
really funny comedy so I had a lot of
fun with Horrible Bosses and I'm going
to give it three and a half out of four
stars so if you liked this review
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes
Oh